今日は外れ社長で寒い季節になってきましたね
というわけで寒い季節みなさん何になりますかあったかい飲み物とかいろいろあると
思うんですけども僕に外のとはちょっとってなっちゃうんで寒い季節あーもうほんと
nars のなくっておりますじっくりコトコトとロリコーンというわけで9世本当に
コンピューター jal 何がイライラするかと言いますと
彼のほうが折れないいっすよあれまずでちょっとうざくないですか
って何度くらデザインですけどダウン際んですけど結局おいしいせね
結局中な幸が美味しいみたいなところがあるんですよというわけで今日の動画は
コンピューター頭の中身なら全部
高温になってる時やっていこうと思いますやあの嬉しいと思うんですよ
ft 伸びますね抱きます
[音楽]
ん
ああああああ
ねえねえやっぱ美味しいですよね美味しい秘訣としてはやっぱり nasa のコーン
が欠かせないなら公が主役みたいなとか言いますからね
[音楽]
うん
ん
いやあああいうことになっちゃうんですよでもこうなっちゃうともう何か病んでいっそ
のことを音符だぞの中身を全部購入したい場合ならなくなるんじゃないかという発想で
ございますいうわけで今から
発目はみゅーずめんとパークに行くんですけどもう菓子入れのコンポタージュを
たくさん準備しましたこれをあえてさらに高また州で飲ませるとでターゲットポンプ車
ってだけでちょっと飲んだところで
ない野外のギター見つけてそのタイミングでコンポタージュをすり替えって全部ホーン
になっているコンポ等を飲ませてあげようと思いますもう多分全部コーナーでめっちゃ
嬉しいんですよもう多少の幸が全部食べれなくても十分な高があるのでイライラが
なくなってしまう脳ずっとですねのベルコーポダンスの完成でございますそうだった時
に果たせターゲットはなんというのか
僕の予想だと多分うれしいがあると思うんですよ
なんでこういっぱいだはいたいなというわけでまずは中身が全部コーンの子2つを準備
して行きたいと思いますはいと言うけどでコーンズん bise ました
これでも今飲んだの奴に移していきますが早速入れていきましょう
ダル
[音楽]
待て
進ぬ
うん
はい
[音楽]
待って来ればれるなぁかさすがにこれはやりすぎですね分かるもんだってこればかりは
さるん
れていた
混ぜ
終わった者は終わったやばいこれず出てこないねちょっと作戦変更でき抜き準備したん
でよくあるじゃないか
なんか昔流行ってた掘ったら全部溢れるやつみたいな感じで
コンポタージュ思ったらコーンが溢れていることにしましょう愛的で準備完了いたし
ましたちょっとこの田んぼ今後すぎるの他のかもボコボコに行きましょううんいい感じ
でもうここになったと思います
して指で早速コンボた笹し気に入って渡して飲んでたら伊豆何か中身が全部コーンに
代わって持ち上げたらコーンがポロってるドッキリだっていこうと思います会はイブ
キャバクラ副尺当然彼はふとた強いですっ
あーやっぱ行ったり money money ね町尾仲がやばいんさをとっても
ありがとうございます
フメイクってん
こういうのあっはぁ
話を塗っています
バッハ
[音楽]
あっ
いい季節たちは探知されない
ジョジョ姉御さん買ってくださいはい
今回てください熱いあるかもグランヴィルジャンキー
パワーイメージを与えましょうえっ
皆さんはください最初へ
ヒャッハー4た
ちっちひゃー沿い
がんばっん
ん
[音楽]
しちゃいますね
あっはぁん
ん
いきますすー
ただしたして放送や骨だって
ちゃすりん
一歩迫れたちょっといるー
わー
待って申請していっ
ですかはぁ
写しっこんなですね
[音楽]
ブルーウェイ
ああ
[音楽]
ベースっ
ありますかもうプレッシャーに変えだったん
安いですかもういいですよ
[音楽]
ああああああ
上
うそーだろ
嘘だろう
知れてチョコですよ c 出てこねぇせよもうこうしか出てこないやっぱコンッ
方も定格ですた方がいいかもですか
penang
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
コンポ男女の中身が全部コーンになっている時でしたね
me
あーわーっていうのがふぅんっ
[音楽]
[ __ ]
せ経費化ですしただの子なんですよね2歳の頃すと
こうねっ
ね